Schönen guten Tag, Berg ist mein Name. Ich bin zuständiger Erste für Sie.
Bevor wir zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden kommen, benötige ich einige persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Anna Röber.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, R, O, also O, umlaut, B, I, R, Röber.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.07.80.
Alles klar.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie können Sie zurzeit sein, Frau Röber?
Ich bin 45.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Okay, wie groß sind Sie und wie können Sie zurzeit sein, Frau Röber?
Ich bin 1.65 und wiegen 69 Kilo.
69.
Danke für die Informationen, Frau Röber. Was für Sie zu uns, was für Beschwerden haben Sie zurzeit?
Ich habe so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Das hat langsam angefangen, aber jetzt ist es immer mehr.
Jetzt habe ich angefangen, ich fieber.
Ich muss mich auch schon zweimal übergeben heute.
Ich habe Durchfall.
Ich fühle mich jetzt auch richtig schlecht.
Ich war als das Antink vor drei Tagen.
Ich war einmal bei meinem Hausarzt und er hat auch Blut abgenommen.
Aber das Blutergebnis habe ich noch nicht.
Da war auch irgendwie nichts richtig zu finden.
Aber jetzt geht es mir so schlecht.
Diese Bauchschmerzen sind richtig stark.
Wie gesagt, mir ist wahnsinnig schlecht dabei.
Seit wann hat es wieder Bauchschmerzen?
Vor drei Tagen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Jetzt sind die rechts unten im Bauch, aber vorher waren die oben so um den Bauchnabel herum.
Da war das erst.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen rechts unten.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich meine, sind sie echa du stechen pürenant?
Nein, erst stechend.
Stechend, meine Sie.
Ja, stechend und ziehend.
Streien und Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, sie sind gewandert, aber ausstrahlen tun sie da eigentlich nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ist das etwas, das die Schmerzen nicht mehr versteckt?
Wenn ich ganz still liege, dann kann ich es aushalten.
Aber in dem Moment, wo ich rumlaufe,
selbst wenn ich nur zur Toilette gehe oder in die Küche gehe, um mir einen Tee zu machen,
dann wird es wirklich schlechter.
Okay.
Wie stark gibt die Schmerzen auch bei einer Schmerzfallafon 1 bis 10?
1 steht für leichte Schmerzen, 10 steht für unterechtregliche Schmerzen.
Ohneertreglich, aber langen kalt ich das nicht mehr aus.
Das sind schon richtig dolle Schmerzen.
Ich würde auch alle Fälle sagen.
Könnten Sie bitte im Ende des Gesprächs diese Schmerzen aushalten?
Oder soll ich Ihnen ein Instrument untergeben?
Nein, ich habe ja schon mal versucht.
Ich habe eine Ibo genommen und das hat aber auch nichts geholfen.
Solange wird unser Gespräch ja nun auch nicht dauern wahrscheinlich.
Wie viele Mal nehmen Sie Ibo-Profen?
Zwei Mal habe ich die jetzt genommen.
Zwei Mal 400.
Eine gestern, eine heute.
400 Minigramm, alles klar.
Sie haben schon gesagt, ich habe 2 Mal Erbrochen.
Und wie sieht das Erbrochene aus?
Das, was ich vorher gegessen habe,
weil ich dadurch Bauchschmerzen habe, habe ich eigentlich überwiegend
bisschen Tee und Zwieber zu mir genommen und habe mir mal ein Pudding gekocht.
Und so richtig, was richtig dolles Essen mochte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Eine Banane habe ich auch mal gegessen.
Das hat man natürlich dann auch wieder gesehen.
Das war alles so gelblich, bräunliches Zeug, was da rauskam.
Okay, alles klar.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Zwieber.
Haben Sie das gemessen?
Ja, ich habe mich tatsächlich einmal gemessen heute Morgen
und da war das bei 38 und da habe ich auch wieder mit Scherzmuster
aber doch mal ins Krankenhaus gehen, ja.
Wo haben Sie das Zwieber gemessen, im Mund?
Mit so einem Sternenhermometer.
Okay, stimmt, alles klar.
Okay, und auch Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Durchfall.
Wie sieht Ihr Stuhl aus?
Ja, das ist so ganz dünnflüssiges, braunes Zeug halt.
Wässrige oder schleimliche?
Eher wässrig, eher wässrig.
Okay.
Ja, ich möchte wissen, können Sie diese Beschwerden,
hatten Sie früher schon einmal enden Beschwerden?
Ja, Bauchschmerzen hat man natürlich schon einmal gehabt,
aber jetzt so in dieser Art noch nicht, nein.
Okay, alles klar.
Nehmen Sie, rühmst du eine andere Medikamente ein, auch sehr überfroffend?
Ja, das, was ich halt regelmäßig so einnehme,
ich habe eine Schildresenunterfunktion
und muss deswegen Algeroxin nehmen.
Das nehme ich natürlich zusätzlich ein,
aber das habe ich wahrscheinlich auch wieder ausgespuckt.
Wissen Sie die Dosierung Alteroxin?
Ich meine, das sind Hundert, da nehme ich eine morgens.
100 Milligramm.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie Bauchschmerzen, Herzlösen oder Luftnot?
Nein, nein, ich habe nur Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, aber Sie sorgfrahen, Polegeful oder Belehrung?
Belehrung, also das würde ich jetzt im Augenblick,
nee, also das habe ich eigentlich nie.
Nein, das habe ich nicht, nein, und aufstoßen.
Na ja, gut, ich musste mich jetzt halt übergeben,
weil mir schlecht ist und dann kratzt es natürlich im Hals
und dann bleibt es ja auch noch so ein bisschen sauer,
dass es so gelacht, ne?
Ich glaube, jetzt bin ich bestimmt aus Schlesa,
haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, also ich habe ja jetzt auch gar nichts,
weil ich so Bauchschmerzen hatte,
habe ich ja auch gar nicht mehr richtig irgendwas,
also was schlecht verdauliches gegessen, also,
nee, ich wüsste nicht.
Und ich möchte wissen, Ihre Durchfall oder wie war
ich das vor drei Tagen?
Weil der Durchfall, das war es glaube ich gestern das erste Mal
und das Fieber war es, habe ich erst heute Morgen gemessen,
weil ich heute Nacht so geschwitzt habe.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß oder Schütterbrust?
Ihr sagt sich ja gerade, dass ich heute Nacht geschwitzt habe, ja.
Nach Schweiß, alles klar, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, ja, heute natürlich schlecht und die letzten Tage aber noch alles
sehr gut, ich esse gerne, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, also seit es mit der Schilddrüse alles eingerichtet ist,
bin ich eigentlich stabil mit dem Gewicht.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, also das geht zum Glück ein und frei,
da habe ich noch nie Probleme gehabt.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schon, also ich bin eigentlich schon auch eher müde,
aber jetzt heute Nacht und die Nacht davor habe ich wirklich
wegen der Baustenmatze nicht gut geschlagen.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie.
Okay, ich habe einige Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Geschichte.
Sie haben schon gesagt, wie ich Schilddrüsen unter Funktionen habe
und gibt es noch etwas mit einer Vorerkrankung?
Ja, also ich habe ziemlich häufig mal Kopfschmerzen
und deswegen habe ich auch immer Hygrophäen im Haus, ja.
Aber sonst habe ich ja nicht nix, nee.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig außer Tiroxin?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig außer dem Elteroxin,
nur eben, wie gesagt, weil Kopfschmerzen dann die Wo.
Okay, habe ich richtig verstanden.
Sie haben gelegentlich Ibuprofen nehmen.
Ich nehme gelegen nicht Iboya.
Okay, Sie haben sich schon einmal operiert?
Ja, aber das ist schon ewig lange her als Kind,
habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen, ja.
Okay, gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, sonst war nix.
Okay, alles klar.
War es früher stationell im Krankenhaus?
Nein, nee.
Also damals als Kind, ich glaube, da bin ich einen Tag stationär geblieben
und dann wieder nach Hause, aber das war ne kleine Sache ja.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannt?
Ja, bisher so, toll, toll.
Bekannt, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas reagiere.
Okay, haben Sie Unverzwechtheit?
Ja, also, was meinen Sie?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie etwas essen, essen.
Ich kann alles essen eigentlich, ich mag nur nicht alles,
aber dass ich da irgendwas nicht vertragen wüsste ich nicht.
Okay, alles klar.
Wie vorstellig gibt ich meine Kinderkrankheit Corona?
Also Kinderkrankheit ist es schon ewig lange her
und Covid, da habe ich drei Impfungen, glaube ich, bekommen
und ja, was ich jetzt so regelmäßig mache,
dass ich auch zur Grippeimpfung gehe,
damit mich das nicht unter so aus der Bahn haut.
Aber sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
was man noch für Impfungen im Augenblick braucht.
Und ich war auch jetzt irgendwie nicht irgendwie im exotischen Ausland,
als dass ich da jetzt so eine große Impfserie brauchte.
Okay, ich möchte wissen, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, eben nicht, gar nicht.
Okay, okay.
Frau Gröber, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich lebe sehr gesund, ich rauche überhaupt nicht, nein.
Haben Sie noch nie geraucht?
Nein, das hat mir nie irgendwie geschmeckt.
Das war, ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen,
ich gratuliere Ihnen, trinken Sie regelmäßig abbeholen?
Ja, also regelmäßig weiß Gott nicht, das passiert sehr, sehr, sehr selten,
weil ich meistens Auto fahre und ja, das ist dann halt nicht,
passt das nicht zusammen, ja?
Also wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt und ja, dann trinke ich mal
ein Glas Sekt mit, aber das ist wirklich sehr selten.
Okay, alles klar.
Nächste Frage ist eine Routine-Plage, nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen?
Ja.
Na ja, so, ich habe früher mal so Tabletten genommen,
um so ein bisschen besser durchzuarbeiten,
aber das ist schon lange her, also das war auch nur eine ganz kurze Phase.
Ein bisschen wie der Name, das Tablette Name?
Nein, das war irgendwie so ein Mittel, was so ein bisschen wach gehalten hat.
Alles klar.
Aber wie das habe ich, wie gesagt, nur in so einer Prüfungsphase mal gemacht.
Okay.
Okay, als nächstes haben wir über die Krankheiten in Ihrer Familie,
gibt es bestimmte oder chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, also tatsächlich hat meine Schwester, die hat eine chronische Dameerkrankung,
die hatten Morbus Kronen.
Ah, okay, es tut mir leid, es ist eine schwierige Erkrankung, ja.
Okay, und Ihre Eltern?
Ja, also mein Vater, der, eigentlich waren die auch lange Zeit gesund,
aber mein Vater hatte dann tatsächlich vor, also mit 75 hatte der einen Herz entfragt, ja.
Aber das ist alles gut gegangen, der ist rechtzeitig entdeckt worden
und dann konnte man ihn gut, also er hat einen Stand dann bekommen und jetzt geht es ihm gut.
Und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist eigentlich so auch fit, die hat nur Knieprobleme
und hat ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen, aber damit läuft sie jetzt auch schon eine ganze Weile rum und kommt gut zurecht.
Okay, okay.
Okay, und wie alt ist Ihre Mutter?
Die ist 72.
72, okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Röber?
Ich arbeite im IT-Bereich.
IT-Bereich, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, sind Sie zuverheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Aber ich lebe mit meiner Partnerin zusammen.
Partnerin, ob ich es richtig gehört?
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Ja, ich habe keine Fragen mehr, Frau Röber.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben wir alles gesprochen?
Ja, ich meine schon, also ich wüsste nicht.
Also, Sie haben ja wirklich viel gefragt.
Ja, also jetzt, so das Hauptproblem sind eben diese Bauchschmerzen.
Das geht mir wirklich nicht gut, ne?
Ich erinnere mich, ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Besuchen Sie Ihr Frauenarzt regelmäßig?
Ja, so ziemlich regelmäßig, doch ja kann man sagen, ja.
Ist Ihre Monatbelutung regelmäßig?
Ja, ich bin tatsächlich komplett unregelmäßig.
Ah, okay.
Entschuldigung, bitte, Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Die Periode ist bei mir völlig unregelmäßig, ja.
Also jetzt ist es auch schon wieder lange her, aber das ist immer so bei mir.
Das kann ich mich nicht drauf verlassen.
Waren Sie deswegen in einem Arzt?
Ich habe das meinen Gynäkologen natürlich gesagt, aber ja, das ist ja nichts Aufregendes eigentlich.
Das gibt es ja mal, ne?
Okay, wann war Ihre letzte Monatbelut?
Ja, das ist 40 Tage her.
40 Tage.
Okay, könnte es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein, also das halte ich für komplett ausgeschlossen. Nein, also das ist völlig ausgeschlossen.
Okay, alles klar.
Okay, ich bin fertig.
Ja, und möchten Sie etwas hinzubegen?
Nein, nein, aber wie geht es weiter? Wo gehe ich hin?
Ah, okay. Ja, es ist so perü. Genau, jetzt zu sagen, das war erst die Schritte.
Wir müssen weitermachen und es gibt noch zwei Schritte.
Zuerst möchte ich Sie Körperin funken und ein paar Brüter nehmen.
Ein bisschen Blut, also etwas Blut abnehmen, ja?
Ja, etwas Blut abnehmen und natürlich ein Bauchutraschall durchführen.
Ah ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja, okay.
Ja, und Ihre Symptome passen gut schon, eine Bilitarmerschündung.
Ah, ja, ja, rechte Bauch. Ja, ja, das weiß ich.
Da müsste ich ja im Krankenhaus bleiben, ne?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ja, und also, Tagmissball muss ich dann nochmal bei der Arbeit anrufen, aber ja, dann schauen wir erst mal, ne?
Ja, ja, okay.
Möchtest du noch jemanden etwas wissen? Ja, gibt es noch zusätzliche Fragen?
Brauben Sie Kinder? Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Okay. Ja, das macht jemand.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Oh, ja, so ziemlich regelmäßig, ich gehe ziemlich häufig schwimmen und ja, so Wege in der Stadt fahre ich auch mit dem Fahrrad.
Da hat sie schon gefragt, ob ich im Ausland war, das habe ich aber auch verleint.
Könnte es sein, vielleicht Sie verdrobene Essen?
Verdorbenes Essen.
Für die Stücke?
Verdorbenes Essen, nein, also ich habe ganz normal gegessen und auch zu Hause und ganz normal gekocht, also ich habe nichts Ungewöhnliches gegessen und meine Partnerin hat auch die gleichen Sachen gegessen und die hat nichts.
Okay, danke schön.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Durchfall haben.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie Durchfall und gab es Bullets dabei?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen, nein.
Und das war ein, zwei Mal, dass ich Durchfall hatte, ja, da kommt ja immer nur ganz wenig und dann...
Ja, wie sagt Ihr Sturz?
War so wässrig, das hat sie auch gefragt, ne?
Hat jemand noch Fragen oder so?
Weil ich glaube, sie hat wirklich sehr vollständig gefragt und ja, tatsächlich ganz zum Schluss hat sie noch die Kurve bekommen, hat noch die gynäkologische Analyse nachgefragt.
Da habe ich doch gesagt, ja, das könnte jetzt noch kommen.
Ja, super, wirklich.
War wirklich sehr vollständig und ja, sind Sie schon bereit fürs Arztgespräch?
Ja, natürlich.
Super, dann können wir gleich weitermachen.
Okay, schönen guten Tag.
Frau Öbererstin, gerade habe ich einen neuen Patientin gesehen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, wie haben Sie gesehen?
Erzählen Sie mal.
Okay, es handelt sich um Frau Anna Röber, die ist 45 Jahre alt, 1 Meter 65 kg, 69 kg schwer.
Wie gesagt, heute bei uns, seit 3 Tagen, 5 Jahren, langsam aufgetretene, starker, stehende und sichernde,
rechtzeitig unter Bauchschmerzen, ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Also Sie hat sich wegen rechtzeitiger Bauchschmerzen, die schon seit 3 Tagen an Anhalten sind und zunehmend sind, hat sie sich vorgestellt, ja?
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen am Anfang Bauchnabel begonnen.
Sag mal einfach Begriff.
Unwilligkeit?
Paranbilikal.
Ja, Paranbilikal begonnen.
Ja, okay.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 bis 8 von 7 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Also hat die ordentlich Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Beim Legen lindert die Schmerzen oder...
Im Liegen, im Liegen sind die Schmerzen weniger, ne?
Okay, im Liegen sind die Schmerzen weniger.
Neben der Schmerzen berichtet sie, pireksi, das war 38 Grad, im Stingemessen.
Auf das Dieren?
Das ist der Schmerz, der die Schmerzen weniger.
Die Frage ist, dass die Schmerzen weniger sind, die Schmerzen weniger.
Ja.
Die Schmerzen weniger sind, die Schmerzen weniger.
Ja, das ist der Schmerz.
Besuchlicht der Vorerkrankungen leidet sie an Hypotroidie und Sefalgie.
Im Besuch auf Medikation nimmt sie ein 100 Milligramm Morgens und Ibuprofen bei Bedarf ein.
Als sie Kind war, eine Tonselektomie wurde bei ihr durscht geführt.
Es bestehen keine Allergien und keine Unverträglichkeiten.
Reisanamnese ist unauffällig, ins Status ist aktuell.
Sie ist nicht Raucherin, sie trinkt ein Glas Sekt sehr selten.
Drogenkonsum wurde ein unbekannte Präparate bejaht.
Das muss klar sein.
Aber nimmt sie das jetzt auch aktuell?
Aktuell nicht.
Okay, in der Vergangenheit hat sie das genommen?
Ja, Vergangenheit.
Okay, in der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass ihr Vater mit 75 Jahren an mir Kartinfarkt gelitten hat.
Einen Mirokartenfakt erlitten hat?
Ja, erlitten hat.
Die Mutter leidet an, Konat Rose und sie ist 72 Jahre alt.
Sie hat eine Schwester und die Schwester leidet an, Morbus Chrom.
Beruflich ist sie IT-Bereich angestellte.
Sie ist ledig, aber lebt mit ihrer Partnerin.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik, nein, ich vergesse, genäkologische Anamnese.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik, vermute ich ein Appendicitis.
Was könnte das Alternativ noch sein?
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Adnexitis, sowie Diverticulitis in der Kracht.
Und was vielleicht noch?
Einfach Gastroenteritis.
Ja, so etwas, ja.
Und eine erliche Faktor für Morbus Chrom, vielleicht chronische Entzündungsdarm.
Ja, genau, das könnte auch sein.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Als Erstentatnahme werde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und, was machen Sie dann gleich, wenn Sie die Patientin auch genommen haben?
Ich werde körperlich untersuchen und Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich da auf Bauchuntersuchung, wie zum Beispiel Oskiltation, Palpation und Percussion auch.
Ja, es gibt eine ganz spezielle Untersuchung.
Aufwärtsspannung und Loslachschmerz.
Sehr gut, ja.
Und als Vitalparameter überprüfen, werde ich Körpertemperatur, Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz, Sauerstoffsektikung überprüfen.
Okay.
Als nächstes im Labor werde ich Blutbild, Entsündungsparameter, CRP, BSG, Elektrolyte und Gerinnungsparameter,
Neurinverte und Blutgruppe-Operation beachten.
Danach werde ich eine Abdominalsonographie durchführen.
Und, was erwarten Sie?
Ja, Entsündungszeichen warte ich, zum Beispiel dicke Wand oder Flüssigkeit.
Preilflüssigkeit, ja.
Ja, genau. Okay, gut.
Und ja, dann natürlich, was wäre die Therapieoption, wenn Ihre Diagnose sich bestätigt?
Wenn meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt, werde ich ja Analgitika verabreichen, ja, vielleicht.
Und was noch?
Und, ja, gastroenterologisches Konzil.
Ja, und was Sie hoffen, ist vermutlich rauslaufen.
Dann würde ich eher sagen, chirurgisches Konzil, oder?
Ja, ja, aber zuerst muss ich einen Zugang legen.
Ja, auf alle Fälle, genau, ja.
Das war erste Schritte.
Ja, ich habe immer vergessen, Zugang legen.
Und Spasmolitika, zum Beispiel.
Spasmolitika, ja.
Spasmolitika, okay.
Und ausreichende Flüssigkeit für.
Ja, okay.
Aber meinen Sie nicht, dass OP-Indikation gegeben ist?
Wenn die tatsächlich eine Appendizitis hat?
Perforation?
Nein, eine Appendizitis.
Ja, CRP, erhöhte CRP.
Und FIBA, Spächen für Appendizitis.
Ja, ja, also wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen, dass ich Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigt.
Ja.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, aber.
Dann ist doch OP-Indikation gegeben.
Äh, ja.
Also heutiger Stand nicht mehr.
Da müssen mich jetzt die Kollegen korrigieren, wenn ich etwas Falsches sage.
Ja, nein, Sie haben recht, wenn die Patienten akute Appendizitis.
Ja, ja, Appendectomy, ja, ich weiß, aber, ja.
Ja, ist doch, ist doch, also ganz klare OP-Indikation.
Deswegen soll ich ja das.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Und deswegen haben Sie, glaube ich, auch die Blutgruppenbestimmen, ne?
Genau.
Gut, was ist denn dann noch eine Frage, die wichtig wäre, die Sie noch nicht gestellt haben?
Ähm, für Operation?
Nee, das haben Sie ja gefragt.
Hm.
Ganz einfach.
Denken Sie an die anesthesiologischen, anesthesiologischen Kollegen.
Hm.
Was möchten die wissen?
Sind Sie nüchtern?
Ah ja.
Ja, genau, letzte Mahlzeit, genau.
Ja, Sie graben recht.
Ja, genau.
Also, das wäre noch eine Frage, die vielleicht zu klären ist, ne?
Ja.
Mhm, ja.
Ansonsten, ja, also, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufen und über die Patientin.
Wir sehen die sicherlich nachher dann noch im OP, ja.
Mhm.
Gut, wunderbar.
Also, Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Ja, danke schön.
Wir haben ein sehr ausführlicher und präzisen Bericht gegeben.
Haben alle, oh.
Ja, danke schön.
Oh ja, Dr. Süle.
Und Tirox.
Sagen Sie einmal, was fehlt?
Sie haben eine Wirklichkeit?
Äh, Tirox wird immer Mikrogramm.
Mikrogramm.
Ja, natürlich.
Stimmt.
Super, ja, aber ich glaube, dass Sie das auch immer gesagt haben.
Das war wichtig, ja.
Mhm.
Ja.
Das ist der Patientin natürlich nicht aufgefallen, ja.
Wir haben Sie gut auf, also, ich würde sagen, das ist eine sehr,
sehr gute Anamnese gewesen.
Es war natürlich jetzt zugegebenermaßen auch ein sehr naheliegender Fall.
Die Diagnose lag so ein bisschen auf der Hand.
Aber Sie haben sich auch sprachlich ausgesprochen gut besprochen.
Ja, danke schön.
Das war also von der, von der, von der Gesprächsführung her,
fand ich sehr souverän.
Zuleit hätten Sie noch ein bisschen mehr, die Patiente noch mal mit Namen
ansprechen können oder so.
Aber eigentlich haben Sie das schon ganz gut gemacht.
Eine Winzigkeit.
Sie haben gesagt, ähm, gynecologische Anamnese war unauffällig.
Ganz unauffällig ist die ja eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Und Sie haben regelmäßige Siklus.
Und, und die hat, insofern müsste man vielleicht,
auch wenn sie beteuert hat, dass das eigentlich nicht sein kann.
Ja.
Hat sie, sollte man sicherlich nochmal ausschließen,
dass die wirklich schwacher ist, ja.
Ja, ja.
Das wäre ja noch tatsächlich so eine,
jetzt in diesem speziellen Fall wegen der Partnerin.
Ja, ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber eine extrautere Gravidität wäre ja,
wäre ja auch noch eine denkbare Diagnose, ja.
Und ja, aber wie gesagt,
das war eine super Anamnese, eine super Fallvorstellung.
Und ja, wann dürfen Sie Ihre Prüfung machen?
Äh, Sante de Samba.
Oh, das ist ja schon bald, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich glaube, da können Sie sehr gelassen, drauf zu gehen.
Ja, ich hoffe, danke schön.
Ja, gut.
Ja, das war eine, eine gute Vorführung, würde ich mal sagen.
Vielen Dank.
Wir sehen uns am...